what I want to talk about today is how
you can become a super programmer like
myself how you can write code like a
real hacker using this one simple trick
so I'm gonna start with telling two
stories there's basically two stories of
how I became a software programmer one
of them was really cool and the other
one is true they're both kind of true
I'm not I'm not just coming up with this
um so I was about 13 i horribly broke my
leg in a sporting accident because i was
a very sporty youth as you can tell and
you know i just i didn't have anything
to do i was like you know it was summer
everybody else was just like chasing
ball chasing tail you know whatever they
were doing I was at home I didn't have
any friends but I had this one friend
and the friend was called IRC but
problem was that on IRC I didn't have
any friends because nobody liked me so I
figured if I would start a channel then
people would come and you know they
would have friends but the way to have
an IRC channel and many of you are too
young to remember this is you need a
boss to keep the channel when you're you
know offline so I started to make a boss
and I didn't really know what
programming was but I heard that you
make BOTS in this programming language
called Perl
so it's like I learned that and that was
pretty chill and then I wanted to share
that with everybody because nobody came
to my channel but I figured if I share
this bot that maybe then we people will
come so I made a website for it because
you know that wasn't github back in the
day so I learned HTML and CSS and
eventually JavaScript and that's like a
really cool story but because you know
involves all the things like open source
and you know being hacker and you know
like I don't know I don't know SSH into
Linux be pcs you know it's all kind of
cool stuff but in actuality I didn't do
anything with that I you know my leg
healed I went back to school I went to
university I studied comparative
literature philosophy major whoo and you
know that there's one side effect of
studying comparative literature is that
you're constantly broke you have
absolutely no money you have absolutely
no skills that you can use to make money
so so so you know you have no basically
ignore no survival so I was mooching off
this girl who I was living with at the
time and she was like you got to get a
job so I went you know and I I got a job
in an office I wore like a suit I got
like a cheapest suit that you could and
I went the
and they give me this massive Excel
spreadsheet and they said this is your
job like okay
and for like about a day I tried you
know working with the Excel spreadsheet
but then I was like alright well that's
probably a way to like automate myself
out of this job and and so I did I I
basically I I learned how to write VBA
macros which is the only language that
is worse than Perl is VBA but but
basically that worked and what I learned
from that experience is two things one
that automating your tooling is like a
[ __ ] fantastic you know ability and
then what I also learned is this concept
of macros so I want to talk to you today
about Visual Studio code how many people
here know Visual Studio code everybody
more or less it's kind of like if you
use sublime text or atom it's basically
like a text editor or slash IDE but it's
made by Microsoft and what's cool about
vs code is similar to atom is that you
can actually write x tensions for it so
you can basically write your own tools
and I've written some tools that have
made me a lot better programmer and I'm
gonna demonstrate to you today by doing
some live coding for approximately many
minutes yeah that's gonna be like this
it's not gonna go well I'm this is like
my fourth beer alright let's do this so
the first thing that you need to do in
order to can you see this cool the first
thing you need to do in order to create
a visual studio plug-in you say yo code
this is not a joke yeah there's this
tool called yeoman generator and you can
install generators for it in this case
it's the code vs code generator and now
if you know this is where you kind of
decided you want to be a real hacker if
I was the kind of hacker that had
actually like gone do with a kind of
pearl and SSH and whatever route I would
choose JavaScript but I'm the Microsoft
guy so I chose subscript we can get a
give this thing a name it's gonna call
AVS code hacker macros and I'm just
gonna say yes to everything I don't know
what that is then we're gonna pray that
NPM install works
cool and then what's gonna open vs code
all right do we see this I'll be bigger
maybe yep cool so I'm just gonna like
quickly show what's here so we have a
package.json this is like an a standard
type script nord project we have some
activation events we have some commands
that we can you know use to kind of you
know give you know basically start our
program and then we have this photo
extension - yes I've treated a little
bit I made this buffers and storage
files that we're gonna like store some
of these macros in but they're not very
important and we don't need to really
look at them right now but essentially
to start kind of doing this I think what
real hackers do is first thing we use
multi cursors I don't know if you know
this you can do a command D and you can
multi cares of course your selection
like this and then you can just delete
it because real hackers don't use
comments so we can delete those real
hackers also don't log anything so we
can delete those so that's fine now we
have basically the simplest possible
vyas code like you know like extension
that you can have so what I'm going to
do is I want to write an extension live
right now that enables you to record
macros that you can use to act like sort
of automate your workflows so I think
the first thing we're going to do is
we're gonna just look modify this thing
this default one we're gonna make it a
recorder I'm gonna implement this in a
minute don't worry and then we're gonna
copy that and make that a play and then
we need one more this is kind of boring
plumbing when we need to over overwrite
the type command in the standard thing
and then what you need to put those in
the subscriptions so we're gonna
cleaning up the thing it's we're not
actually going to clean up anything
there's the activate method you're
supposed to do something here but we're
not gonna go to real hackers don't
actually free resources so that's one
thing now the next thing we're gonna do
is going to implement this recorder real
quick it's relatively simple all related
to do is we're going to need to create
basically like your storage class and
then we're gonna create
we're gonna need to put that in
disposable we can I need to put some
some handlers it's pretty simple let me
just see if we can tune this up a little
bit bad on all right
it's so this bit is a bit tricky where
we need to basically we need to kind of
like register some of that so and if you
can see that but it's like yeah it's
like boring plumbing I think this is the
thing about typescript it's like you
know you need to write this all this
[ __ ] code that you normally like
wouldn't have to anyway so that's the
way that works anyway I ran out of beer
I'm gonna need somebody to help me any
volunteers can I have them oh no no no
Richard you you misunderstood me come
here
all right Richard is this mic on yes
yeah can you tell me what is your name
all right Richard I'm gonna go get a
beer
if you finish this program for me so
it's very simple just implement like a
replay class and you know the things
just whatever you do do not press
backspace or Harrow keys because that
will [ __ ] everything up
so uh yeah that was that was that
basically what this thing does
has anybody see this website called
hacker typer yeah so this is hacker
typer but you record your own own hacker
typer kind of thing so what I'm actually
doing here right now is implementing
this thing and then we can just go into
the debug mode we can start debugging we
can open a new instance of Visual Studio
code and then within here we can we can
basically just say record macro and then
now I can say hello reactivate ten
except ah no not ten I'm just gonna do X
instead and I can save that macro I'm
gonna give a name react want to call it
one reactivate so it sorts and then
hopefully I should be able to oh it
doesn't sort cool so now I should be
able to just play what I just recorded
including things like selections and
multi cursors and you know whatnot so
this thing is called vs code hacker
typer it is in the in the visual studio
code extension marketplace it's
absolutely free I don't know why they
call it marketplace I don't think you
can make any money on this but you know
Microsoft's I guess at anyway so so this
is what I made thank you
so I have a couple of real quick things
so V escort hacker typer is there you
can use it but you might you know when I
good why would anybody make something
like this but also mostly importantly
why would you want to use this and I
think I don't remember what my slides
are okay so why did I make this one of
them is one of them is that I've always
really wanted to be like the one of the
people who can do live coding but I just
can't I'm like like really slow typer
and it makes such typing mistakes and I
get very very nervous
but at the same time I would like to you
know have you know this tool that I can
use to actually like communicate really
really complex ideas to people and
sometimes the best way to communicate
about code is to show the code but you
can't just show the massive amounts of
code and all those things that Claire
showed you know the tools that we can
have in presentation that ITER's and
things are great but the best way to
understand code is be able to jump
around it you know like look at things
explain explain them I believe here I
might have I already broke this I can't
show you but you can go you can kind of
like go and and mix things up and you
know like highlight things and then just
keep continue typing and it kind of kind
of works the other thing is I wanted to
explore like and truly this story about
excel wasn't like hokey Kitsch it's it's
really like where I started really
programming and now that you know like
we have you know these tools that are
automatable in the programming languages
that we all know or obvious code type
script or JavaScript what are they kind
of see like how can we do this and V
escort accessibility is really really
great what I I'm not a big fan of
typescript as a programming language I
like if you have a language that has the
word type in it it should probably do
type checking but it doesn't actually
work like there's so many it's horrible
so many broken things in it that doesn't
actually you know like correctly it's
validate you know the types of your code
but that said you know this experience
of learning how a BS code accessibility
works couldn't have been easier I did
not read any documentation all I went is
like okay well let's see what this
automated generator gives me and explore
the you know the API via the auto
completions and all that so I thought
that was like a really really great
experience now I'm gonna leave you with
this
really topical we are ever there's
another quote from ray tracing our
friends a formidable homemade victory so
we are basically a software consultancy
that you know that's a lot of open
source stuff so a victory that Richard
mention is something that we made
spectacle that Claire used I something
that we made and a bunch of other things
as well and you know we are hiring so if
you want to work you know on this kind
of like cool oppressor space please do
talk to us and the most important thing
about this is why did I really make this
is recently formidable started to pay
people for any open source contributions
they do on their free time
which means I got paid for this [ __ ]
which is you know pretty incredible so
that's it thank you very much
[Applause]